everyone thinks they know doordash it
dominates food delivery in the united
states and is making inroads
internationally but what if i told you
that most of the things you thought
about this company were wrong or that
doordash's own founders don't even
consider it a food delivery business so
what kind of company is it i want to
start by talking about these you know
macaroons it might sound kind of crazy
but they're a really important part of
the doordash story let me rewind a bit
doordash's co-founders tony shu evan
moore andy fang and stanley tang all met
at a stanford business school course
called startup garage tony who remains
the ceo to this day was in grad school
there with evan andy and stanley were
undergrad compsci the guys were brought
together by a shared insight the
creation of early portable payment
systems were unlocking a huge stream of
potential commercial activity for local
merchants armed with this knowledge they
started pounding the pavement in their
neighborhood they'd ask local businesses
what problems they'd solve if they had a
magic wand the first idea that the team
came up with was to create an ipad app
which would ask a restaurant's customers
how they heard about the place not bad
improving customer acquisition is great
but not a multi-billion dollar idea for
that they'd have to go to a macaroon
store in downtown palo alto called
chantelguyon the version of the story
that's passed into legend is that tony
and his team members were about to leave
the store when the owner said actually
there is one thing i wanted to show you
she got out this thick booklet with
pages and pages of delivery orders this
the owner said pointing to the booklet
drives me crazy i have no drivers to
fulfill these orders and i'm the one
doing all of it tony evan andy and
stanley realized that this was the big
unmet need they'd been looking for
inspired they bought the domain name
palo altodelivery.com and uploaded pdf
menus from a bunch of the top
restaurants in palo alto on january 12
2013 they went live with the website
they got their first order for pad thai
within an hour and they just kept coming
there were two more on launch day five
the day after then seven then ten the
guys immediately saw that there was
demand for what they were doing but that
demand created a puzzle for them to
solve how would they take orders how
would they communicate those orders to
the restaurant and how would they track
the progress of deliveries tony set up a
google voice number for the team so any
incoming calls would go to all of their
phones at the same time they'd then ring
the restaurant and place the exact same
order drive over pick up the food and
take it to the customer once they
started bringing more drivers on board
they'd use the find my friends feature
on their iphones to track the deliveries
that first iteration was pretty janky
but they were tackling a genuinely hard
coordination problem food delivery is
harder than ride sharing because it's a
three-sided equation with ride sharing
you've got customers and drivers one
source of demand and one source of
supply to meet that demand there are
still tricky optimization problems but
it's kind of a basic model restaurants
introduce a second source of supply into
this equation orders can't be fulfilled
without the input of both the driver and
the restaurant you've either got a
driver with no payload or an order
getting cold at the restaurant as tony
put it you need to nail 15 small things
to get one delivery right except for
pizza places food delivery was rare
before companies like doordash came
along that's because restaurants had to
create and maintain their own delivery
operations they had to hire and pay the
drivers they had to track the progress
of deliveries and make sure the whole
system ran smoothly basically they had
to solve both sides of the supply
equation themselves only a few
restaurants could take on that type of
complexity most understandably didn't
even try which is why what palo alto
delivery was doing was genuinely
innovative and hard the team saw that
they had an idea which resonated with
restaurants and customers local
restaurants liked that their food became
visible to a bigger group of customers
customers loved it because they didn't
have to leave their apartment to get the
best pad thai wings or hummus in town it
was just the beginning but the
opportunities were getting bigger every
day so the guys said to each other let's
do this for real 100
but they needed to learn more about how
delivery actually worked so tony and the
rest of the team actually signed up to
be domino's drivers for a few weeks they
even drove for fedex for a while this is
more than an amusing little anecdote
it's a great example of the approach
which has typified the company's journey
an obsession with operating at the
lowest level of detail for doordash's
founders operating at the lowest level
of detail meant learning about the nuts
and bolts of delivery years before they
became a billion dollar company learning
how delivery actually worked meant they
could apply it to their business that
meant reducing costs passing savings
onto restaurants and customers and
outsmarting their competitors fully
committed they applied to y combinator
and were accepted into the 2013 summer
batch for tony evans stanley and andy
this was a signal that they were on the
right path but they'd only taken the
first steps first things first they
ditched the name palo alto delivery
because they didn't want it restricting
their addressable market the team used
three criteria to come up with their new
name it had to be easy to spell ideally
it would have two syllables or less and
the domain name needed to be available
there's that commitment to operating at
the lowest level of detail with this
little algorithm in mind they came up
with the name doordash no more palo alto
delivery then they cleaned up the
website they ditched the pdf menus and
got proper restaurant pages getting the
small details right is important but
without the right strategy it doesn't
really matter the team was about to
confront their two biggest choices by
far looking back they might have been
the two most important calls they ever
made how they handled them tells us a
lot about the kind of company these guys
were building y combinator culminates in
demo day where you pitch to a huge group
of investors and the summer 2013 cohort
was extremely competitive in fact when
techcrunch published an article covering
the top eight most promising companies
in the batch they didn't even mention
doordash the doordash team had come up
with a pitch that would stand out from
their competitors this was it the moment
that would determine if doordash could
make it to the next stage and secure a
solid funding round after demo day they
needed cash to scale up their operations
so they had to nail their pitch when
tony and the team presented doordash
they made a bold claim they weren't a
food delivery company they were building
a logistics business food delivery was
just the first use case it was audacious
but they knew that they could back it up
companies like grubhub and seamless
created demand for restaurants that
already managed and operated their own
delivery infrastructure doordash's pitch
was that in exchange for a share of
revenue they would build that
infrastructure they would take on the
risk of managing a workforce and
optimizing delivery routes doordash was
helping restaurants solve the delivery
problem by stepping in to be that second
half of the supply equation it was a
totally different approach to what their
rivals were doing this might mean
sacrificing early market share and
interest from certain investors but it
was a model that doordash could apply to
industries beyond food and this is that
lowest level of detail doordash raised
2.4 million dollars in seed funding out
of yc it wasn't a huge raise even then
companies were coming out of the gates
raising 5 million or more but it was
enough with that money in the bank the
founders had to make the second of two
huge early decisions where to expand
they started in palo alto where do you
think they went next san diego la maybe
outside of california how about san jose
specifically east san jose i want to put
this into context for people who might
not understand how unorthodox this was
san jose is a big city in the bay area
but east san jose is the suburbs
families who own homes and walk their
dogs down leafy streets that kind of
thing it couldn't possibly have the
density that a company like doordash
needed to turn a profit right wrong
because once again doordash saw
something others didn't first the
founders realized that the higher rates
of car ownership in the suburbs would
mean a greater supply of drivers but
their more important insight was that
expanding into the suburbs would allow
doordash to refine their operation and
introduce their business to customers
without much competition and here we are
again operating at the lowest level of
detail to get an edge this first move
beyond palo alto went well enough that
in may 2014 doordash raised 17.3 million
dollars in funding from sequoia capital
just 15 months after the guys were
driving around making deliveries
themselves they were now in charge of a
series a company valued at 73.5 million
dollars there's this great photo that
stanley took from right around then he's
holding his computer science homework
his tax forms a speeding ticket and the
sequoia term sheet it was a crazy time
and they were just getting started that
series a funded doordash's expansion to
los angeles and the team ran the same
playbook there lock down the suburbs
first the first location outside of
california was boston that choice was a
really interesting signal about how
doordash was thinking about the
challenges of expanding into big cities
boston is big but it's also very flat so
it's great for cycling those conditions
presented an opportunity to experiment
with dashers on bikes who could weave
through heavy traffic better than if
they were in a car again they were doing
things differently and finding small
ways to outsmart the competition in
march of 2015 a 40 million series b
round led by kleiner perkins valued
doordash at 600 million dollars doordash
was operating in eight markets but by
the end of the year they were active in
22 including two in canada interestingly
at this stage all of the 65 employees
even the co-founders were actually
required to deliver one day per month so
if you were near the stanford campus
around then you may have had your order
delivered by tony stanley or andy that
close proximity to the actual operation
of the business meant that the team saw
things that others couldn't they saw
that dashers needed access to dedicated
elevators their own parking spots and
separate serving stations at restaurants
the doordash team was deep in the weeds
and finding tons of small improvements
that would add up to a big competitive
edge so far so good but things were
about to become a whole lot more
complicated doordash was getting a lot
of publicity and it wasn't all good
publicity by 2015 several restaurants
were claiming that doordash had uploaded
menus to its website without permission
which meant that sometimes prices were
different on the doordash website than
at the restaurant and like many gig
economy companies at the time doordash
had to grapple with whether or not their
delivery drivers should be classified as
independent contractors or full-time
employees moving fast in a new industry
led to tons of tough decisions and
doordash was facing a ton of competition
as well grubhub still had by far the
biggest share of food delivery in the
u.s and uber which was flush with
investor cash launched ubereats often
the best thing to do when you're under
pressure is to grow so fast you can't be
caught unfortunately just as that
pressure ramped up doordash stumbled
sequoia was encouraging the team to
raise a series c round and was prepared
to commit 40 million dollars as long as
another firm was leading the round so
tony went out looking for a new vc firm
to lead doordash's series c he started
looking and he kept looking eventually
after six months it's now march 2016
doordash closed a 127 million dollar
series c round that valued the company
at 700 million dollars just 100 million
dollars more than the series b round
2016 was a rough year for the company
the us economy grew by just 1.6 percent
which spooked markets and slowed
investment doordash added only six new
markets across the whole year that
underwhelming funding round meant that
it needed to be careful with its cash
customer acquisition was still expensive
and their other costs weren't really
coming down its market share had grown
to 10 but that paled in comparison to
grubhub 70 and uber was burning through
money trying to enter the same on-demand
delivery market that combination of
slowing growth high costs low margins
and ambitious rivals has killed off lots
of promising companies it could have
done the same to doordash in fact it
nearly did in late 2017 the company
raised a 60 million loan we only learned
about this three years later when
doordash went public and we got to see
their s1 which is the sec document
companies file pre-ipo to this day we
don't know for sure which investors
provided the loan doordash may have been
weeks away from running out of cash and
yet by august 2018 it was valued at 4
billion
how do you explain this incredible
turnaround from near death to an almost
6x increase in value success has many
ingredients but there are three things
that stand out first is that in 2017
doordash began turning a profit on a
per-order basis this didn't mean that
the company was suddenly profitable
overall but at a time when common wisdom
said it was impossible to run a delivery
company without burning through piles of
vc money it was vital to demonstrate to
investors that you were making progress
towards that goal the second reason is
that doordash's existing investors kept
the faith companies like sequoia were
smart enough to know that doordash's
business model and commitment to
operating at the lowest level of detail
was enough to beat the competition
provided they survived the tough times
their faith was rewarded sequoia and
other long-time investors held big
stakes in doordash when it began
dominating the industry the other reason
can be boiled down to basically just one
thing softbank the softbank vision fund
was placing big bets on delivery and
ride sharing around this time this
included being one of the biggest
investors in uber softbank led
doordash's 535 million dollar series d
round in march of 2018. doordash was now
a unicorn but a highly deluded one
softbank and other investors had just
taken a 38 slice of the company it was a
high price to pay but it gave doordash
the cash it needed to hit the
accelerator and that's exactly what they
did in august they raised another 250
million dollars at less than five
percent dilution when they weren't even
actively looking for more investment
that round valued doordash had four
billion dollars which is a huge
valuation but deliveries grew by 250
over the course of 2018 so clearly
things were going well by the end of the
year the company was operating in more
than 3 000 markets thanks partly to big
chains like chipotle and ihop signing up
that massive increase to their footprint
enabled doordash to overtake grubhub to
become the number one food delivery
company in north america by march 2019.
from the verge of extinction doordash
was going stratospheric in may doordash
announced another massive funding round
which valued the company at 12.6 billion
dollars this valuation came on the back
of 60 growth since its series f
expansion to 4 000 markets in north
america and its dash pass service
approaching a million subscribers and in
2019 doordash made 880 million dollars
in revenue off of 8 billion in gross
order value tellingly the company
extracted 60 more revenue in 2019 from
the same restaurants that were on its
platform the previous year its growth
wasn't just broad it was also deep so
nothing could stop it right sometimes
companies generate enough momentum that
only two things can change their
trajectory a black swan event or an
unforced air in 2019 a new york times
piece revealed that rather than going
straight to dashers customer tips were
only going to them if they otherwise
wouldn't hit a guaranteed minimum take
in practice it meant that millions of
tips were going straight to doordash not
dashers it was a public relations
nightmare delivery drivers work super
hard for what is often low pay without
benefits strategically it was also a
risk wasn't doordash kind of admitting
that it needed this tipping scheme to
make money it quickly reversed the
policy but that was too late to assuage
people that thought that doordash was
too eager to move fast and break things
and investors started to get concerned
that doordash's unit economics wouldn't
hold strong without the tips the issue
of worker classification is extremely
complex but before that could be
resolved there was the small matter of a
global pandemic beyond its human costs
covid19 destroyed incumbent business
models disrupted supply chains and
accelerated existing social and economic
trends it was terrible news for
businesses that relied on foot traffic
but it was absolutely incredible for
doordash in march of 2020 the company
grew by more than 20 percent and they
were already massive at this point from
being nervous about the entry of
ubereats into the market and the head
start that they were giving up to
incumbents like grubhub doordash quickly
captured half of the u.s market in june
it raised another 400 million dollars in
funding at a 16 billion valuation but
november 3rd brought a prize that was
arguably even bigger 59 of voters in
california voted yes on proposition 22
which meant that rideshare and delivery
companies could classify their workers
as independent contractors rather than
employees entitled to benefits gig
economy companies had always argued that
classifying their workers as employees
would force them to raise prices and
dordash clearly thought the outcome was
important to the viability of their
business model they spent almost 48
million out of a total of 200 million to
support proposition 22. that argument
isn't over though in august last year a
judge overturned the law created by the
passage of proposition 22 and gig
economy companies are appealing the
ruling a very similar proposition will
be on the ballots in massachusetts this
november and it's going to be an
expensive fight but doordash is such a
large company now that worker
classification issues in a few states
aren't really an existential threat
anymore after all doordash was now big
enough to start planning an ipo and the
combination of the pandemic
turbocharging demand for food delivery
the outcome of proposition 22 and a
buoyant market for tech stocks gave it
the perfect opportunity the ipo priced
doordash at 102 per share by the end of
the first day of trading the shares were
now valued at 189
an 86 increase for the day in a season
of absolutely crazy tech listings
doordashes was one of the most
ridiculous and the stock price kept
climbing now obviously doordash hasn't
been immune to the broader downturn in
tech stocks there's a ton of factors
affecting the public markets right now
and increasing volatility but there are
other numbers that tell us much more
about why this company has emerged as
the market leader in food delivery in
the united states it's still not
profitable but it is reliably generating
positive operating cash flows investors
aren't watching the profit numbers
though they're looking at revenue growth
and doordash's revenue has exploded 1.3
billion dollars in q4 of 2021 compared
to less than 300 million dollars just
two years earlier total orders increased
from 83 million in all of 2018 to 369
million in just the last three months of
2021 and they've done a great job
increasing customer loyalty nearly
quadrupling the amount of money each
doordash customer spends on average the
company's huge market reach means its
marginal marketing and customer
acquisition costs are decreasing this is
what happens when you get the flywheel
spinning doordash's latest earnings
report put its gross order value at 42
billion dollars in 2021 but compare that
to amazon which generated a staggering
600 billion dollars of gross order value
in the same time frame and you realize
that despite being a big fish doordash
is swimming in a medium-sized pond the
size of its addressable market is the
biggest constraint on its growth the
doordash team knows this though in fact
they've been preparing to overcome this
constraint for years remember what tony
and his co-founders told yc at demo day
back in 2013 we're not a food delivery
company we're building a logistics
business the platform that doordash
built helped restaurants deliver food to
their customers but food was only ever
the first use case since then doordash
has diversified its product offerings to
consumers and merchants let's start with
dashpass launched in 2018 dashpass is a
membership program where subscribers pay
9.99 a month for free delivery from
qualifying partner merchants it's the
same basic concept as amazon prime and
allows them to extract higher revenues
from the most dedicated customers the
average order from a subscriber does
generate lower contribution margins but
these members have higher retention and
higher order frequency which drives
faster growth in the last quarter of
2021 this dash pass program surpassed 10
million subscribers then there's
doordash for work which launched in
october 2020 and enables employers to
feed their staff while they're working
from home this allows employees to make
subsidized doordash orders employers get
to keep their staff at their desks for
longer and doordash opened a new revenue
stream and that's not all doordash now
has three new products aimed squarely at
merchants doordash drive launched in
2016 is a white label last mile
fulfillment service that allows
businesses to deliver orders that
originated from outside the doordash
ecosystem effectively piggybacking off
the large pool of dashers and the
company's logistics operation storefront
launched in mid-2020 enables merchants
to manage online orders by creating a
simple website this is valuable because
doordash estimates that 40 of its
restaurants don't have any kind of
online ordering system and its most
radical product offering is its most
recent in early february 2022 doordash
announced doordash capital a program to
offer merchants cash advances that they
pay back automatically with doordash
sales doordash calls this a cash advance
not alone merchants are charged a
one-time fixed fee instead of a typical
interest structure and the amount a
merchant will be eligible to borrow will
be based on its past sales history with
doordash doordash capital is quite
different from past product offerings
which have fundamentally been consumer
loyalty programs or initiatives to
encourage merchants to use the company's
logistics operation nevertheless this
shows that along with its sustained
growth in non-restaurant orders doordash
has its eyes set on bigger markets than
just food delivery since it was founded
doordash has been asking every question
and questioning every answer when they
graduated from yc the food delivery
market was dominated by grubhub in 2015
uber which was far more heavily
capitalized launched ubereats yet
doordash rose to meet every challenge
its rivals critics and external forces
put in front of it today it has 58
market share in the united states up
from 17 at the end of 2017 but in such a
competitive industry there's no such
thing as a permanent victory the story
is still being written and there are
many challenges ahead new rivals and
entirely new service models are rapidly
emerging to challenge incumbent firms
like ghost kitchens which are
restaurants with no storefront at all
more on that in a future video so be
sure to subscribe international
expansion is always complicated the
medium-term macroeconomic outlook is
uncertain profitability remains elusive
and what will happen to revenues as we
move past the pandemic all unanswered
questions but for now doordash leads the
way in food delivery in the united
states commentators and analysts have
offered many reasons as to why superior
customer acquisition and retention
command of unit economics a diversified
product portfolio better investor
relations all of these are true but
they're all ultimately a subset of
something that i've been emphasizing
throughout this video doordash has
mastered the art of operating at the
lowest level of detail rather than chase
grubhub it worked from first principles
to construct a fully operational
logistics business which allowed them to
expand quickly it devised an elegant
solution to the three-cornered demand
and supply equation it made the
brilliant decision to expand into the
suburbs and use them as a lab to build
its profile and refine its delivery
model it partnered with the right
restaurants at the right times it
achieved per-order profitability years
before uber despite the latter's
formidable financial advantages it has
ruthlessly committed to scaling its
speed and it has laid the foundations to
diversify well beyond food delivery
doordash has played tough and they've
made some enemies but when faced with a
strategic choice that would shape what
kind of company doordash became they
made the right decision almost every
single time that's what has enabled
doordash to create a customer experience
which has become an important part of
people's lives i love that doordash has
become such a y combinator success story
if you're interested in learning some
key lessons from y combinator be sure to
watch this video next thanks a lot